every single day we've got a makeover
led by a member of the drew crew and
today we're going to honor waitress and
mom christine condello
[Applause]
hi my name is christine cadello i'm 45
years old and i'm from fairport new york
i've been married 23 years to my
wonderful husband vinnie and we have two
awesome kids i've looked the same for
the last 10 years i've had the same long
black curly hair
my makeup was always the same i've been
taking care of my kids for so long that
i never really took time on myself i
haven't had a professional haircut in
probably about three years i've been a
waitress for 27 years so i've always
wear the same uniform i just want to
revamp my look drew can you help me out
please
i know
we would be honored to honor you and
christine's daughter eva is in the
audience to see her mom's transformation
ava
thank you hi hi
hi
ava what do you think that this makeover
means to your mom
i'm honestly just really excited for her
because she
ever since me and my brother were
younger she's just done everything to
make us happy
and i feel like this like today will
mean the world to her because she's
always wanted something done like this
you think she like always puts everybody
else first yeah and she's like
she's not as confident as she should be
i feel like she's always putting herself
down we tell her she's beautiful but
she just well see
here's where i find actually
the
beauty aspect most important
is because
makeovers you know they're important and
they can definitely boost our confidence
and they can distract us for a little
while but ultimately our inner dialogue
is going to overpower anything that
happens on the outside because that's
being locked in a cage on the inside
that we all need to work on i think we
all have the traps what do you think is
a trap for her in here
i don't know i think the main thing
she's focused on right now is the
outside but
i just know
i think she will feel very confident
after she sees herself
all done up because she doesn't like
she hasn't been in a while i feel like
it'll make her feel a lot better about
herself yeah
what if
we make her a little card that we can
put on her mirror that you can write
yeah
that'll that would be awesome put a
different message in her head that she
can see right next to the mirror when
she's looking yeah you know what we can
call it a makeover and a mantra yes
yes i love it
well
someone who is my go-to as a girlfriend
a makeup co-founder
a absolute amazing mother and an
incredible woman is beauty maven and my
dear friend zanna roberts rassi
and she is working her magic right now
um and we're gonna show a big reveal at
the end and we're gonna work on that
card during the show okay are you okay
thank you ava
thank you so much i'm here with makeup
legends zanna roberts rossi
the
co-founder of milk makeup and also you
know one of the world's greatest fashion
editors and i love coming here the
compliments just keep on coming i mean
you really are it's like you know by the
way which do you if you had to choose
fashion or beauty what would you choose
um because they're so inextricably
linked in the two yeah that's the thing
it's all about making people it's not a
cop out answer but i do feel like it's
all intertwined it's about making feel
people feel good
from the outside so they feel great on
the inside and then it's projected on
the outside again beauty and fashion
okay you're right i mean it is all
inextricably ranked all right well
you've been busy the entire show helping
christine
kind of work a new look after 10 years
of being stuck in a little bit of
monotony and we all can get caught in
that trap oh yes uh but christine's
daughter ava and i have been um
co-conspiring and patiently awaiting um
a little bit of a transformation a
little jesus little boost
um and i can't you're not gonna believe
this i'm so good
i i mean i've done a fair few but this
is
so good and your mom is incredible she's
such an insanely wonderful woman lover
well as a mother of two daughters
yourself
um i can't wait to see what you've done
no tears get your waterproof mascara out
ladies all right christine
come on out
ah
oh i feel amazing
that was gonna be my question how do you
feel god i feel amazing i'm
i've looked the same for so long that
i just i feel amazing i feel 10 years
younger
i feel beautiful
[Music]
okay so xana when christine wants to
harness this and channel it what are
three makeup tips that she can go to so
when it comes to foundation
don't think that heavier coverage is
actually going to give you a better
coverage often with more mature skin it
dries down and then sits in wrinkles and
fine lines so a light weight coverage
foundation is best serum-based something
hydrating so then we added this balayage
technique so that is something that just
lightens the load as well it gives
dimension so it's not just one monotone
color so that really lifts and softens
secondly when it comes to anyone with
even slightly hooded eyes try and almost
carve out the crease in the socket here
using a darker shadow because it adds
that definition and also use an eye
primer it's the product you didn't know
you needed until you use it because it
stops that transfer all over the eye
area and also transformation with the
hair is instant
i mean if anyone wants an instant lift
chop off a few inches with every inch
she's like turning back 10 years of time
because it lifts the face turn to
beautiful ava your gorgeous daughter
and ask what you think i love it so much
um as long as you feel confident and you
look confident you're happy then i'm
happy for you i do i do i feel
very confident
i'm always very hard on myself
so i feel amazing
and then you can have the power the
power jacket as well if you're really
feeling like you need a little bit more
power move there you go oh my god
that's great
[Applause]
okay um christine we have a little
surprise for you everyone in the
audience contributed
to this
and so we made this for you during the
hour-long show
and um they
wrote
basically a word that came into their
mind
when they saw you
um but ava will you show where your
message is it's the pink and blue one in
the middle
i love you
and be confident today
[Music]
[Applause]
radiate
enough
indulge this is great we all need one of
these in our lives the mantra board is
amazing thank you
so
this
is from everybody here today thank you
so much you guys for contributing to
this so we can foster this memory and
this moment and you can channel it
within the snap of the fingers you can
look at this and if you're starting to
criticize yourself in the mirror you
look and you take those eyes off that
mirror and you look at this board i will
thank you
all right well my sister in beauty zanna
used our flower beauty stellar prismatic
highlighter
and everybody if you want to look and
feel your best go to milk makeup because
it is the best in class
and it is my favorite beauty line
and i want to kick off beauty week right
by giving every single member of our
audience a 50 gift card to
flowerbeauty.com
really good
i want to thank christine and ava
you and everybody thank you for choosing
to spend your time with us
[Applause]
[Music]
you